we've been hearing about apple's plans  to launch a completely portless iphone  for a couple of years now i do agree  that apple will be using the magsafe  puck to make the iphone go portless  apple filed for magsafe puck patent back  in 2017 they originally planned for it  to handle data transfers as well there  are two optical data transfer modules so  that data will flow into the puck and  down the cable to a computer they'll be  transferring data by shining light  through a puck optical window to send  and or receive data to a device such as  an iphone researchers at eindhoven  university of technology achieved a  transfer speed of  42.8 gigabits per second using infrared  light to transmit data that's faster  than the 40 gigabit per second  thunderbolt 4 standard that we have  today but you unfortunately wouldn't be  able to use an iphone case while  transferring data with the mac safe puck